abone ol
[Müzik]
ne yaptın mı
bu başarıyı
bu formüle edebilir miyiz başarıya giden
yollarda formüller var mıdır ya da
başarıya giden yolun kestirme yolu
vardır bu işi sürpriz bu Ben bugün size
hayatı boyunca karşılaştığı zorlukları
gelmekte kullandığım birkaç düşünce den
bahsetmek istiyorum ben Bursa bir
girişimciliği hayatı boyunca bir şeylere
girişme konusunda içinde büyük bir
heyecan buldum ve girişimcilik konusunda
çok heyecanlıydım ama o zamanlar
girişimcilik Ne olduğunu gerçekten
bilmiyorum öyle bir kelime ya da ve bir
kavram yoktu liseden Bu Aslı ilkokuldan
bir süre gibi şeyleri girişler cesarete
doğru sildim üniversiteye gittik
O çok havalı bulduğum için reklamcı
olmak istedim reklamda olabilmek için
elinden geleni yaptım de Reklamcılık
kulüpleri kurduğun reklam etkinlikleri
yaptım sonrasında reklam ajanslarına
gittim saçlar yaptım Metin yazarlığı
yaptım ve aslında bir arkadaşlarına
rüyalar girişimi olan reklam ajansını
kurdu x
bu video öğrencisiyle tableti kobi'lere
ve uyguladıktan çözümleri sunmaya
başladık Ve
bu fark ettim ki ben gerçekten yürekten
de olmak istemiyorum
Ya oğlum yani çok özür dilerim
bilmiyordum ne yapacağım yani hayal
ettiğim şey asla istemediğini fark ettim
Sonrasında da boş durmamak için yeni
şeyler denemek için önüne gelen pek çok
şeyi değerlendirdim aslında ettim sattım
tezgahı açsın kitap satıcılığı yaptım
Finans işinde çalıştım çok işi denedim
Aslında sonrasında önüme birlikte bir
girişimcilik yarışması fırsatı çıktı Bir
sene süren bir yarışmacı ve size hayalet
veriyordu veriyorlardı onunla bir çift
yapmamız gerekiyordu Bir sene süren Bu
proje yarışmasında çok iyi çok heyecanlı
bir şekilde iyi mi iyi bir şekilde bunu
bir o şansını yakaladım
Bu çok güzel bir sürü ya gibi be bir ol
çok iyiler gazeteler röportajlar yaptık
iletin dergilerinde röportajlarını
şifalı bir öğrencisin gerçekten çok oldu
ya
şu anda ya ben girişsiz oğlum kim olarak
biz olacağım harika gel yoklamada Zaten
işte çok heyecanlıyım başarılı oldu
ne olur o zaman hayatım Böyle grafiğin
hep
ben seni soruyordu
bu bölgeleri gelecek Hadi gel girişini
yapalım Sen kovanları uzandı olayım sana
bu elbiseler yapalım diyeceksiniz ama
öyle bir dünya olmadığını çok hızlı bir
şekilde öğrendim ben
şu an öğretmen çocuğuyum ve onlar Tabii
ki evet çocuklar için Garanti de güzel
bir de yaptırıyorlar onların isteği
vasıtasıyla mezun olduktan sonra da asla
başladım ve bankadan ticari portföy
yöneticiliği yaptım İlk önce benim
olarak aldıkları için iki yıllık
sözleşme uyguladılar ile çok ağır bir
Depresyona girdim ben ne yaptım ben
geçmiş olmak istiyorum bankacı oldum
diye iki yıl boyunca bunu da in diye
bakış açısı geliştirdim ve dedim ki
burada bu iş yapmak zorundayım iki ben
bu
ama getirebilirim diye baktım Ticaret
bak önce söyledim yani benim işim
söylüyordu ticari şirketlere Kredi
vermek onları bilançolarını incelemek
rasyonlarına bakmak ve Aslında onlar
öneriler vermek ve birtakım ürünler
sunma söyledim ki ben girişimci olmak
istiyorum Benim elimde legal olarak bir
sürü bilanço var Bu ne demek ben bir
şirketlerin Aslı çok gizli bilgileri çok
hızlı bir şekilde yaşayacağım Yani şimdi
ne kadar para kazanıyor kim ne kadar
kardır kim ne kadar zararlı herşeyin
görebiliyorum de sonraki süreç boyunca
aslında aldı götürdü benim için de
oynamıyor geldi Hem o gözle baktım bir
yere bir şeyler yapacağım şu anda
kendimi yetiştiriyorum diye Aslında bir
hayalim olmayan bir şey olmasına rağmen
sonra için transfer oldum bu
federasyonda sıvıların kurduğu
federasyonluğu özelliği Türkiye'nin en
önemli on beş tane kurduğu bir
Federasyonu ve Türkiye
bu şekilde sektörü ticari hayatına
etkide gelecek fikirler geliştiriyor duk
bir şekilde göre öğrendim O siyah olan
pişti boşuna siyah olmuşlar hepsi
birbirinden farklı özellikleri
birbirinden farklı alsın yetenekleri
vardı Şimdi çok hızlı karar veriyor
kimse çok uzun düşünüyor kimse çok ciddi
etkisi çok mantıklı ve hepsini özelliği
vardı o
İyi ki gerçekten mükemmel insan yok Ama
kendisini iyi tanımış kendisi doğru
yönlendirmiş insan var orada en önemli
edindiğim farkındalık buydu sonrasında
artık böyle birşey söyleme gelince
kurumsal hayatta dedim ki ben kendi
işimi yapmak istiyorum kendisine hapisim
istifa ettiğinde Bu karar verip istifa
ettiğinde bir sonraki ay kira ödeyecek
param yoktu ilk işim Aslı Bu şartlarda
hazırladım abim kullanmadığı atölyesi
kullanmadığı altı zamanları kullanarak
Aslında yola çıktık ve direnci inat
ettik zaten direnmek zorundaydık Çünkü
bir sonraki arkamızda gördüğünüz
gerekiyordu ifadem para kazanmaya
başladık ve üçüncü aydan itibaren dıb
çıkışımızı yalnız alma fırsatımız
olmuştu
şu anlık bahsettim bir akışkan bir
Aslında karayolunda
Ya aslında benim mi Hangi işleri yaptığı
hangisini bildiğin değil aslında benim
size bahsetmek istediğim şey tam olarak
bu
en sevilen farklı işler yaparken işin
Ya aslında hayatımızı baktığımı Neyle
neyi sevmediğimi bir yataktan değil
bıraktığını ya da yat anneyi Zımba gibi
böyle bastırdığını asla gördüm ben seni
seviyorum hadi insanlarla çalışmak
istiyorum hangilerini uzak durmak
istiyor musunuz net bir şekilde gördüm
mecbur istifa ettikten sordum
bu farkında olarak yaptığım işte
birbirinden farklı değeri var Kimisi
saygı görmek istiyor Kimisi güçlü başarı
ki para bu saygılarımızı fayda olduğunda
bir iş yaptım ve o yüzden 5 yıldır o
girişimi ilk girişimi ayakta tutan
ilmeği boş aldım ama
bu olarak çalışıyoruz ve onların
sürümüyle bana yapıyorum bize
geldiklerinde iş görüşmesinde çok kalın
boy kalınlık bilgilerle geliyorlar ve
birbirinden farklı işlediğini olur
sinirlerin değişiminde benden
bekledikleri soru şu oluyor işte Ne iş
yaptınız burada öğrendiğiniz size de
katabilirsiniz bir soru sorduğunda ki
var o zaman Onu sormuyorum Ben şu
soruyorum sumo işte hiç söylüyorum senin
o işte değil Sinir ediyorsunuz sizi o
işine yapınca sinirleniyorum bu sorular
soruyorum veriyorum çok büyük bir
şaşkınlık ifadesi ile karşılaşıyorum ve
genel olarak yani katılımcıların yüzde
doksanı sonra Mevlit veriyor bu
bu güçlerden tekrar olmaya başlıyorlar
karşılaştıkları olaylardan bahsediyorlar
uçuyorum muoi şey kendisinin farkına
varıyorlar farkına vardıkları için yer
kendi değerlerini bilmedikleri için de
asıl oradan oraya sağlık duruyorlar
bence sorun var mı diye sordum ya sorma
o gelecekti o harika zaman Kendinizden
başlıyor bu hayatta ne istiyoruz bizim
değerimiz de ne olduğunu SCX kafa tam
olarak bundan başlamanız gerekiyor
Ne yapacağız şimdi bir kere bulmak
istiyoruz yola çıkacağım bir şey
yapacağız ama nereden başlayacağız önce
bir bakış açısı geliştirirse ki yapmamız
gereken şey bir bilgi bulmak
ben size değerlerimiz var diye şu
aslında sizi heyecanlandıran sizi olur
Bu kardeşine anlamadığınız bir şey
buldum neyse onu olduktan sonra
birleşsin onun ok
e Okul girişinde aklı çizgili ve
zamanımız yok spesifik bu bilgiyi
bulduktan sonra ileri Neşe başladıktan
sonra algıda seçicilik olacaktır
Etraftaki tüm bilgileri Türk
disiplinleri kendisini ziyaret etmeye
başlayacaksınız
Bu bir uzaylı şudur susuz bilgi a bir
okula öğrenilmez bir oto ile bir işte
derse öğrenilmez Yoksa gidip sizi sahip
olamazsınız bir sıkıntı bir sahip olmak
ister
o kendi Değerinizi hayattaki
beklentilerini bulup birleşiriz
gerekiyor buldunuz artık birazcık para
kazanmak istiyorsunuz nasıl düşüncem
dedi geliştirebilirsiniz işte
ve Herşeyden öncekini bir modelle iş
yapmak önce
çok az parayla çok boya çok para
kazandığınız ya çok fazla kişiye
gittiğiniz Aslında iş modelleri ama
böyle bir model elde etmek istiyorsanız
önce dediğim gibi kendi spesifik
alanımızı belirlememiz lazım yani şurada
para varmış ama buraya gidelim değil
sizleri seviyorsunuz gelişimlerini de
98'in batma sebebi Aslında gerçekten ne
istediğini bilmeyen orada bir popülarite
da moda var diye gidilen ama aslında
istediğin şey olmadığını bir bilmeyen ve
zorlukta Arapçası tek izlemesinde
ayaklarının kaymasına neden olan şeyler
Aslında bunlar
Evet şimdi evdeyiz benim sevdiğim
bakışlarından Birisi Evet şöyle diyelim
vardı bir şey buldu ki şifremizi bulduk
nasıl geleceğimiz buldum yani bunu
Herkes biliyor ama bazı başarılı
başarısız oluyor ama şu düşünceler
bedenimiz fikirler
iyi bilmemiz lazım şey doğru gelişiyor
ölüyor ya da tekrar gelişiyor bunu Biz
de seni seviyoruz bye
bu girişimleri başarılı başarılı
kişileri birbirinden ayıran şey şurada
gördüğünüz ölüm noktasında olup olmadığı
yada tekrar eski üstünüzde bir tane daha
istemesi koyup koyabilme başarısı
bu tipler örnek vermek istiyorum e
sevgisinin en tepesinden ölüm tarafına
geçerse bizi tanıdığı bir şey yok Nokia
Yusuf bir marka Nokia dünyanın en büyük
telefonu markasında markası iken bir
anda battılar ve artık işini telaffuz
etmedi bir hale geldi bu hafta da yok
artık biz ileride bilgiler çok düşük
hizmetler satılan Şimdi Derken en yüksek
teknoloji gerektiren gerçekleri görmeyi
de en önemli yaptığı hata şuydu Ben
olduğum yapıyor Ben de okuyayım Ben
dünyanın en tepesindeyim zaten böyle
görüyor ve teknoloji giriyorum dedi ve
sonrasında olan bir kaç yıl içerisinde
klima düşüşe geçtiği ve oldu bu
gerçekten yaşayınca en kötü durumlardan
birisi diğer şeylerden güzel gördüğü
geçmek istiyorum isimlerden Birisi bir
kasso
Allah hepimizin bildiği çok popüler ve
sağa doğru popüler yapan şey ne biliyor
musunuz hiç durmadan yorulmadan almış Şu
an arkamda gördüğünüz görsel onun erken
benim resimlerinden birisi karakalem
yaparak başlıyor karakalem iş eserlerini
görüyorsunuz sonrasında Nasıl notları
bacak başarmaya çalışıyor sonrasında
gerçekçi resimler yapıyor ve sonra sonra
hayran olayım kızlar ve güvenlik ortaya
çıkıyor Bir gördüm
çok kötü motor falan ya
ne diyordu satılıyor mu evet bırakmadı
değil
Allah rahmet bir tane şehri çizdim en
Kapıya geldim eve gittik biz oradan
atıyorum orada devam etti sonunda bugün
bu bahsettik Aslı oldu bıraksaydı buraya
kadar gelecek ismi olmayacaktır
sen adını telaffuz ettiğimiz herkesin
Ayrı özelliği var bırakmıyorlar tepeye
Gelseler bile ben oldum demiyorlar benim
oğlum diyen kişinin gideceği yer
maalesef ama maalesef ördüm şimdi
bahsettik yani biliyoruz her şeyi
anladım çok çalışmam lazım Çok
Bu sene herkes başarılı değil Yani ne
oluyor başarısız oluyoruz psikiyatrist
ve ona göre şöyle şu oluyor ölüm
bu hangisine ölüm bir verdiğiniz aldık
hissettiği döngüyle değişik gerektiğini
söylediğimiz insanın hissettiği döndü
ayrı Tamam diyoruz yani birisi size
değişen gerekiyor değil de az önce haber
almış gibi hissediyorsunuz Bence söz biz
bekliyoruz
Ya oğlum canım öyle şey diyoruz sonra
kızmaya başlıyoruz sonbahar gelmeye
başlıyor durumda
abone ol
21.45 bölümü oluyor bir duruyoruz ve
sonra da kabul ediyoruz ya bu çok işimiz
börekten örnek vermek istiyorum size
İngilizce mesela Bence zorlandığımız
gerekiyor çok geliyorum Gerçekten örnek
İngilizce öğrenmesi lazım bizim evimiz
öğrenmesi gerektiğini sonra ya ya
Teknoloji gelişti gözlükler büyük işler
geliyor bu kadar zaman harcamanıza gerek
yok yağmıyor vh diyorum öğrenmeye olan
var mı
devam ediyor O
bu teknoloji gelmediğini fark ediyor
zaman geçiyor bir sesiniz yok ortada
kızmaya başlıyorum AOL
Bu pazar gibi yatıyor Tamam ben çeviri
öğrenmiş kendini altı bilecek kadar yani
sadece kadar konuşuruz ya onu da
yüklediğiniz görünüyorsun yaşına giriyor
zaman kaybettim ben diyor Ne yaptım ben
diyor ve sonrası kalıyor Anne söyle
oluyor bak
Abi başınız insanları bu sahnede
konuştuğunuz insanlara konuştuğumuz
insanları anne gittiğimiz nokta bu bu
kadın
[Müzik]
her şeyin farkındayız Evet sonra bir
gerçek var Bundan sonra ne yapıyoruz
Bizim Kaderimiz belirleyen bizi mutlu
huzurlu ve başarılı Clash şey asla
bundan sonraki davranışını sevdiğinden
sonraki hayattaki bölümümüz O yüzden ben
size bir soru sormak istiyorum
en son olarak sizi gördüğünü
neresindesiniz ve bundan sonra
hayatınızda neler yapacaksınız
teşekkürler